President Trump has a new nominee to be
the US ambassador to the United Nations
this morning mr. Trump announced that
Kelly Knight craft the US ambassador to
Canada is his pick to present or
represent the u.s. as you at the United
Nations the announcement comes ahead of
the president's second summit with North
Korean leader Kim jong-un that will take
place next week in Vietnam
Nikole Killion is at the White House
Nicole good morning good morning to you
and top American and North Korean
negotiators reportedly met this week in
Vietnam ahead of next week's summit
between president Trump and Kim jong-un
the president will be headed there in
the coming days but back here at home
there's going to be a lot going on his
emergency declaration at the border
faces a congressional challenge and the
special counsel is inching closer to
completing his report is not a
consideration President Trump said on
Friday a drawdown of US troops from
South Korea where nearly 30,000
servicemembers are stationed will not be
up for negotiation during next week's
summit with Kim Jong on I think that
North Korea and Chairman Kim have some
very positive things in mind and will
soon find out earlier in the week the
president said he wants to see North
Korea denuclearize but I'm in no rush
there's no testing as long as there's no
testing I'm in no rush you need a road
map of how this ends and when it ends
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham urged
the president to close the deal so my
hope is that we'll set a plan out over
the next year so where you can
denuclearize but officials at the White
House we're taking this one step at a
time
tried to tamp down expectations for the
summit we're not gonna be naive in the
process we know we have a long way to go
as the president takes his 11th foreign
trip domestic issues will remain in the
headlines on Tuesday the Democratic
controlled House of Representatives is
expected to vote on a resolution to
block the president's national emergency
declaration to fund a wall along the
us-mexico border we have too many smart
people that one border security the
president said he will not sign such a
resolution if it passes the House and
Senate
will I veto it 100% 100% and while away
in Vietnam the president may not have to
deal with the release of special counsel
Robert Muller's long-awaited report just
yet a senior official at the Department
of Justice tells CBS News Muller's
report will not be delivered to attorney
General William Barr next week the
president said he expects to discuss the
report with his newly confirmed Attorney
General at some point I look forward to
seeing the report if it's an honest
report it will say that if it's not an
honest report and one that chairs up
several House committees sent a letter
to the Attorney General telling him they
expect the Mulla report to be public
Michelle so a lot of questions Nicole
thank you very much